Star Wars Jedi Survivor story takes
place five years after the events have
fallen order and is going in an
interesting Direction give an embargo
restrictions I can't talk about what and
who I specifically most enjoyed during
my three hour preview of the game so
you'll have to trust me that Survivor
sets up some intriguing ideas and teases
some potentially interesting character
Dynamics in its second chapter it's
unfortunate that I was less impressed by
a lot of what I can actually talk about
and more by what I can't but the sequel
to one of the best Star Wars games is
shaping up nicely in Survivor you once
again play as calcisus who finds himself
struggling to keep ahead of the
ever-expanding threat of the Galactic
Empire while also fighting against them
all these years later the Empire is
still expending efforts to hunt down and
kill any Jedi who managed to survive
Order 66 and Cal's exploits in Fallen
order have made him a key Target the
preview I played picked up at the start
of survivor's second chapter with Cal
crashing the Mantis and setting out to
find replacement parts for the ship
Greece Sierra and Marin aren't around
leaving Kalin his Droid companion bd1 to
Adventure alone I'll admit I haven't
been all that excited for Survivor
leading up to this release in 2019 I was
hungry for stories like Fallen order
which was exploring a relatively
untouched segment of the Star Wars
timeline at the time Beyond a handful of
stories like Star Wars Rebels and Star
Wars Darth Vader the post Clone Wars era
was still a largely unknown period in
Disney Star Wars Canon that's no longer
the case in 2023 with bad batch Ander
tales of the Jedi and Obi-Wan having
further expanded on the era and the
various factions struggling for survival
under the Empire's Shadow so seeing
Survivor yet another story said during
this period wasn't all that exciting but
Survivor seems to subvert expectations
in its second chapter potentially tying
the mystery at the core of his story to
completely different time period the
high Republic first unveiled in 2020 via
a multimedia project of comics novels
and web series The High Republic is a
300 year period that ends roughly 50
years prior to the events of The Phantom
Menace it's essentially the Republic's
golden age and when the Jedi Order was
at its peak it's also very new to the
Star Wars Canon and hasn't been explored
much outside of comics and a handful of
books to see that the next chapter in
calistoria is heavily tied to the high
Republic is a surprise and a delight
especially since the implication of what
I played seems to be that Survivor will
help bring more of that lore and history
forward into the present day of the
Skywalker Saga again I can't talk about
the exact details yet just know that it
seems like fans of the high Republic
stories are going to find a lot to love
in Survivor and if you have no idea what
the high Republic is I think Survivor
will provide ample reason to pay closer
attention to the time period And Seek
more information about it survivor plays
like its predecessor armed with a
lightsaber and half a dozen force
abilities Cal thrives even in the midst
of a heated firefight able to reflect
shots back at attackers and Perry melee
strikes though Cal can cut through
weaker enemies in a single blow well
stronger targets will have to be
overwhelmed first shifting away at their
posture weakens them enough to finish
them off and this process can be sped up
by using the force to rip away Shields
or armor slow thrust through standstill
or trick enemies into attacking one
another like Fallen order survivor's
combat is fast paced and rewards quick
thinking and reflexes the sound design
makes every action point essentially
Star Wars whether it's a deftly
deflected Blaster Vault or powerful
force push like any good Jedi Cal adds a
little Flair to every swing of his
lightsaber in motion it looks cool as
hell however this does make it a bit
tricky to track exactly when when attack
animation ends and the next begins and
without that context reliably pairing
can be tricky this was an issue in fall
and Order and it's disappointing to see
it rear its head again in Survivor Cal's
Dodge at least feels a bit more reliable
this time around but it's frustrating to
mess up a Perry in a lightsaber duel
because I didn't realize I was still in
the midst of an attack anime Nation I'm
hoping this is something that becomes
easier to deal with as you spend more
time with the game and become more used
to Cal's movements Cal starts out with
all the abilities and Equipment he
unlocked during the last game giving you
access to a double-bladed lightsaber
that can also be wielded as a single
bladed saber or split into two Sabers
each of these three combat Styles has
its own strengths and weaknesses calcium
more easily focus on dealing quick and
Powerful hits to a single Target when
using the dual wield style for example
while opting for the double-bladed
fighting style makes it easier to deal
with larger crowds Survivor adds two new
Styles cross guard slow but powerful and
Blaster ranged but they weren't a part
of the demo I played though I think all
of these lightsaber fighting styles look
cool in motion the demo didn't make a
good case for why the game features so
many of them I never encountered a
situation where I needed the wider
swings of the double-bladed style nor
did I meet an enemy that moved so
quickly that I felt the need to switch
to dual wield after trying out the three
starting Styles in the first 15 minutes
I switched to a default single blade
while and never went back this feels
more like an issue with enemy design at
least in this limited early chapter of
the game there's a healthy variety of
enemy types in Survivor Shield wielding
foes who can more easily block your
attacks for instance and agile assassins
with blades of their own who can go Toe
to Toe with Cal but there aren't any
that have resistance or immunity to
specific lightsaber styles of what I saw
anyway at least in terms of lightsaber
Styles Survivor isn't encouraging you to
evolve and adapt fight to fight there
are enemies who better respond to
certain Force Powers some foes can fight
against being Force pulled or pushed but
most fights play out the same since the
lightsaber is how you mostly deal damage
and there doesn't seem to be anything
encouraging you to switch up your style
in the moment-to-moment skirmishes it's
hard not to compare Survivor to other
games where the main character's Arsenal
features a singular weapon that can
change forms the flavor Combat on the
Fly Like Metroid Prime or multiple
weapons where each serves a unique
purpose like God of War Ragnarok
Survivor doesn't seem to stand up to
such comparisons with its peers the
three hours I played are any indication
hopefully enemy design and combat
scenarios further evolve in later
chapters to better sell why it's worth
putting in the effort to learn the
different combos for all five styles
otherwise I'm not sure why the game
provides as much Choice as it does it
doesn't seem worth spending your time
and spreading your ability points across
five separate skill trees I'm also not a
fan of Survivor resetting the group
dynamic of the Mantis crew and splitting
everyone up prior to the start of the
game meaning the first big step of
Kyle's journey is getting the gang back
together the crew disbanded from a
fraction in ideology Cal feels like he
has a responsibility as a Jedi to do
everything he can to keep fighting the
Empire at every possible turn while
agrees Sierra and Marin all want more
than a life of constant Rebellion is a
tried and true storyline especially
within Star Wars but one in which the
most interesting part the cause of the
dissolution and the moral ramifications
of it has already happened all we're
seemingly left with is rounding up the
group we already spent bringing together
in Fallen order the preview didn't
showcase much of this process I
recruited grease when the preview ended
but given how little conflict there was
between Greece and Cal it does make me a
little worried that the interesting part
of the storyline has already passed us
by there are new characters for Cal de
befriend this time around but most of
them don't seem to be joining the Mantis
crew instead Cal can send them to a town
called rambler's reach on the planet
Kobo where they'll hang out in the
Cantina that Greece owns offering Cal
optional side quests and opening up
shops with cosmetic items as you
progress in the story new conversations
open up with these characters these new
NPCs are very hit or miss one in
particular who ties back to that
aforementioned High Republic mystery is
incredibly memorable and fun to talk to
as is Droid bartender mxnk6 AKA monk but
I can't even tell you the names of
anyone else they're just not all that
interesting to speak to and don't feel
like actual characters just yet it's
clear the game wants you to come back to
this hub-like area repeatedly to
interact with these people Cal can also
buy music to play in The Cantina and
find Seas on other worlds the plant a
garden on the roof but a hub is only as
good as the characters in it and in the
three hours I had I didn't even want to
take the time to revisit the town or the
Cantina while I was still on Kobo unless
the game is going to force me back to
interact with the people I'm ascending
there or these characters evolve in a
meaningful way I don't see myself ever
wanting to take the time to go back to
Kobo much like the lightsaber Styles it
currently feels like a Superfluous
system that could just as easily be
included with folks calling Cal
overcomlink to offer side quests my
final major gripe with Survivor is the
villain the game seems to be setting up
to be the major big bad this time around
I can't talk about them giving embargo
restrictions however so I'll leave my
analysis for a later date granted again
I only was able to play three hours of
the second chapter of Survivor there's a
chance that the game addresses many of
my concerns in later levels as I said
from the jump there are some cool pieces
of lore and awesome characters teased in
these early hours I just can't talk
about them yet Survivor has its moments
here's hoping it all comes together and
respawn sticks to The Landing Star Wars
Jedi Survivor launches for Xbox series X
slash S PS5 and PC on April 28th